hi uh so uh I'm currently a ml engineer
at noonam so nonam is a battery health
analytics uh analytics platform so we
where we deploy models and understand
the security risks and as well as health
uh Health analytics for the lithium ion
batteries it can be running on uh
regular EVS it can be running on two or
three wheelers or even large in other
storage systems so uh due to the nature
of the deployments that is in this
scenario so we had to uh take care of uh
I mean thought think about uh deploying
the models on the edge to provide the uh
inferencing faster quicker and to to
also uh address the issues of the uh
critical uh security loaded inferences
so there are quite a things that I
learned while running the running neural
networks on an uh microcontroller or
even uh neural accelerators so
just to start with get things started
uh first thing that comes to mind that
is the is when to deploy on the edge or
when to deploy when the edge is
mentioned here is that edges it can be
on a mobile system like Android and iOS
uh it can be uh on microcontroller to
compare and uh uh Raspberry Pi or even
newer luxurator chips so the four things
that drives everything to the for the
decision is uh
mentioned in the slide so uh starting
from first first to uh first to Fourth
uh so in reduced uh priority so if the
system has to be very low latency like
you have to do inferencing very quick
and the number and the response time has
to be very very low then this is the
most useful and most ideal scenario uh
to deploy on the edge second is the
Privacy scenario where you don't want
the data to leave the source system of
the user system but also you have to
provide the inferencing there as well so
a running neural networks or running any
kind of model there itself so that is
the that is the two most biggest part of
determining when to deploy on the edge
four fourth and sixth uh third and
fourth pointers points are uh it depends
on the situation or depends on uh the
environment of the deployment so since
some cases uh the devices or the systems
or in the deployment environments are
quite Network constraints for say in a
rural environment where the network
availability is not that much uh so the
in that case you have it would be easier
or if it would be actually very user
friendly if the networks or the
inferencing happens on the edge so that
there is not too much to unfrow from the
central from the server from wherever it
is running AWS gcp or even Azure so
there's not that too much flow from the
server to the on the actual Edge so that
the user can get the information as
quickly as possible without worrying
about Network constraints okay you are
you are waiting for uh or at least you
are monitoring for some events or
monitoring for some uh marker and
certainly the networks drops or suddenly
the uh the speed of the network drops
very drastically so that is a very hint
very huge entrance in uh critical
critical situations where it is actually
absolutely needed and the fourth point
is throughput so for say uh the number
of inferencing you are doing per second
is quite high so in that case it also
makes sense to deploy the whole neural
network or the whole uh inferencing
engine there itself if it's possible do
it there or otherwise some somewhat of
some part of hybrid uh inferencing
should be there
so these are the four primary points to
consider on to even start thinking about
if the solution needs to be deployed on
the edge or not
so considering that considering the
earlier slide that when to deploy then
the second part comes into is the type
of deployment that can happen so I mean
in in normal scenarios that you train
the neural network with large amount of
data and then you run inferencing on
information so in that state there are
multiple things that happen
in normal uh ml app scenarios that you
have to do containers monitoring you
have to check for data drift you have to
do model refreshment if the if there is
significant data Rift observed so in
that scenario two kinds of uh deployment
can come into picture one is the
training also happens on the edge as
well as the inferencing so that is the
bread and butter of the whole topics of
federal learning so since this is that
would be a huge part I'm just glancing
over through it what it is and what are
the uh use case or what are the
markers for that so
they're always going to be a base model
to start to start with so the base model
gets trained on the user data which the
data doesn't leave at all from the user
devices at all so down the base model
gets trained on the weights and biases
gets updated and in cases if it needed
the model gets and the updated models
with the weights and buyers get shared
it can be shared with the with a
centralized uh in normal scenarios a
centralized MLF system or it can be
shared in other shared devices as well
so that is the in very products uh run
training at the edge and inferencing
that itself so one of the biggest
advantages the data never leaves
so uh the second point that was
mentioned in the slide one that uh
privacy scenario what when to deploy on
the edge that is the biggest uh
advantage of federal learning or
training on that so the user data never
leaves the source system and only the
model gets trend on the specific data
itself so in contrast to a centralized
model training and serving scenario so
each model each uh each user data or
each deployment devices uh gets trained
differently and each amount of each kind
of model refreshment happens there
itself because at the end if all the
training happening is or happening on
the edge
including the inferencing and this also
goes to
a very customized model uh deployment
for specific set of users and specific
segment of users as well
so just glancing to the training at the
ad Edge then comes in the inferencing
and the edge so here is the
this is the primary point of the whole
uh whole Talk itself that uh when how
what happens while doing the inferencing
at the edge itself so in this scenario
the uh all the training all the
validation everything happens uh in a
centralized manner like normally how
model training happens only the
inferencing happens on the edge so the
edge can be in the same scenario age can
be a mobile device uh H can be a neural
actuator it can be uh hdps as well
depending on the scenario depending on
the environment
so one of the biggest drawbacks is that
it is very diff it would after the
deployment uh the model update depending
on the scenario or the data or the data
the model update of the model
refreshment is quite difficult to do
because the there is no amount of
training happening on the edge the only
thing happening uh there is the
inferencing so all the training happens
offline in a centralized scenario so uh
that is one of the biggest Advantage uh
disadvantage of while doing inferencing
at the edge and in both of the cases the
two big one biggest factor to determine
even which neural network to use what
architecture to use is the memory
constraints memory constraints question
in the term of the total memory usage
and even the total footprint of the
model itself
so that is that well that brings part to
the uh second part which is how to
reduce the model size itself so that
total model footprint gets reduced and
as well as uh memory usage also gets so
that is where the model quantization
part come into picture
so in normal scenarios when the model
gets trained all the parameters whites
and biases everything gets stored into a
into a 32-bit floating Point uh
Precision format
but to store that amount of to store uh
all the weights and biases for each
layer layer
for in in a 32-bit floating Point
Precision format it will take a lot of a
good amount of space if uh the if the
idea is to run it on the edge it can be
microcontroller or uh neural
accelerators
so the point is to reduce the Precision
floating Point Precision from 32-bit to
16 bit or 8-bit integers so uh so to do
that I mean uh to actually go from
32-bit to 16 bit or 8-bit the one of the
biggest drawbacks is the loss of
accuracy how much accuracy is lost uh
how much latency uh is gained through
that through that loss of accuracy and
the trade-off between them
so uh
while determining the trade-off that how
much accuracy loss of accuracy is is
acceptable uh with the gaining latency
this uh
actually there is not that much accuracy
laws can accuracy loss uh is uh evident
while considering the gaining latency so
they say the attached uh references are
in line with the tensorflow light model
optimization toolkit where uh doll the
model size gets almost reduced by three
to four times with minimal loss of
accuracy or in some cases in some cases
what the almost all the new all the
layers are conventional con convolution
uh layers uh the loss is actually very
negligible
uh
so while determining what kind of
quantization to do this plays a bigger
big picture because uh
the the amount kind of quantization that
is preferred on any of the or any of the
process will determine that the amount
the trade-off between the accuracy laws
and the latency gain
so there are primary two types of
quantization currently
currently in practice or currently being
deployed in current scenario so two
parties the post uh training
quantization but all the quantization
happens after the after the model model
is trained so here the Collision is from
uh by default uh the floating Point
position is such a little bit from that
to 16 bit 14 floating point and then
eight bit integer integer integer points
uh Precision ones so depending on what
kind how much the Precision Point needs
to be used different libraries different
framework supports different uh types of
hardware for the scenario
for that scenario in some cases for
saying TF flight TF flight uh model
optimization toolkits uh
different kinds of uh post training
quantization uh prefers either CPU GPU
or hdpu uh or even microcontrollers in
that in that scenario so uh primarily
all the post running quantization is
divided into three uh three primary post
quantization methods
uh one is uh
reducing from 32-bit to 16 bit floating
point and that is reducing from 32-bit
to 8 bit floating Point another is the
dynamic range so in all of this in all
of the type different types of
quantizations the accuracy loss is
almost negligible when dealing is almost
negligible while dealing with post
training with uh Post Trading
quantization with 16-bit floating Point
Precision so in that scenario if it's
suitable for CPU and GPU both and for
and uh the accuracy loss is
almost negligible while uh considering
the amount of latency gain or the amount
of memory Footprints uh memory footprint
set so almost uh four times reduction in
memory size of the model with very
negligible amount of accuracy loss that
that uh that level of accuracy loss goes
uh slightly bit higher once you once uh
the type of quantization goes up so for
say in dynamic range that is the list
among the rest uh barring uh floating
points of 16 of
sorry uh float uh floating 16-bit
floating Point precision and uh eight
bit integer Precision gives the uh gives
the highest amount of accuracy loss
among the three
although being being uh although being
the lowest amount of uh
producing almost five times uh reduction
in model size the accuracy loss is the
highest here because that is
understandable as the Precision Point
comes from 32-bit to eight bit integer
systems foreign
training so in earlier scenario the
quantization happens after the model is
trained everything is in process then
the quantization happens in quantization
of our training the conversation happens
while the network is being changed
itself so uh in this scenario from it
all boils down from 32-bit floating
point to eight bit integers with
negligible amount negligible uh loss in
accuracy so uh but the only the one of
the primary drawbacks is that it is not
supported in most of the most of the
edge Hardwares and on top of that are
very small amount of
a very small amount of uh very small set
of neural effects actually is supported
currently
so among the two types of uh
quantization methods and the different
quantization methods inside in in
subsection of them the second part is
that which one to choose and in What
scenario
so uh the ideal Synod the ideal the root
of thumb is if the whole idea is to just
reduce the size
simple post training float 16
quantization would give almost uh for
three to four times law reduction in
memory size with negligible accuracy
loss so uh if the idea is to just reduce
the size by uh half or even twice that
amount that would almost reduce almost
take all in almost all of the scenarios
now if the loss of accuracy is the loss
effects is much more required or in it
is much more uh evident to reduce weight
gain in with reduction in model with
reduction in uh memory footprint of the
model size then post training dynamic
range or post training 8-bit integer uh
would be uh Preferred Choice but in that
scenario the accuracy loss would be
higher with gain in latency and with
reduction in memory footprint
so they are always straight up between
which one to choose and it will always
depend on uh which one to prioritize so
in scenarios where uh the amount of the
model size is the reduction in model
size is is acceptable within the range
that in all in almost 80 to 90 percent
are scenarios float simple Post Trading
uh 16-bit floating Point Precision
quantization would work
so apart from oral quantization itself
there are two primary or two very pop uh
widely used methods of uh to reduce the
size of the model
one of the one of the major among them
is weight sharing so in white sharing
all the whites of the individual
individual layers are clustered into n
number of or clustered into n number of
clusters and uh
to while sharing the weights instead of
sharing the actual weights the centroids
of each cluster in scenario n clusters
would be shared so in that scenario it
will almost reduce to almost 50 percent
model size would be reduced with again
with the same amount of loss in same
amount of negligible loss in accuracy so
with just simple weight sharing itself
when there are multiple multiple uh
layers of
multiple layers and each layer's weight
needs to be reduced uh reduced quite
significantly without losing much
accuracy and almost one and a half at
least 50 percent reduction in the model
size itself it would give the one of the
it would give the most easiest way to
reduce uh model size and this would
happen again after the model is trained
and everything is done before the
deployment this can be done easily so
the same way post Quantum Post Trading
quantization happens this is also how
happens while after the training is done
another popular method another useful
and I think
um very widely your mother is pruning
what the insignificant parameters is
removed all together while dealing with
the uh while dealing with reduction in
the model size so
so the whole point of deployment from
training to uh on from training to the
edge Hardware is just to reduce the
amount of model size the whole model's
footprint of the model without losing
much accuracy so that trade-off will
always comes down to which one to choose
which one to prioritize and how the
networks or how the types of neural
networks are being chosen so each time
each uh each choice each choice in each
cases while choosing quantization to
reduce the size also choosing any other
reduction method for say uh weight
sharing or weight clustering would feel
different results and would be suitable
for the scenarios that the model is
being deployed
so um how the bank how the each uh
each uh
microcontrollers each hdpus or even uh
popular uh uh neural accelerators
perform which different kind of neural
networks which under different kinds of
load uh so the all the benchmarks all
the uh benchmarks are required and the
added papers is added uh in The
Benchmark section
um I think with that uh all all the
references are also added here I think
with that I can conclude the whole talk
thank you so I am reachable over
LinkedIn Twitter and GitHub as well I
think this slide will also be shared
with all of you